welcome back to pj chain design mother's
day is coming
so i would like to show you how to do
this prawn set
modest ring are you ready let's get
[Music]
started
so we're gonna starting with the facet
stone round
in whatever size that you like if you
like to get the stone to practice
just sign up a newsletter and then you
will get a link for it
all right so now we have this um i'm
going to starting from the
ring size and in my demonstration i
would like to use 16 millimeter
and then you do wanted to have this
sitting
not too low because if set it to low the
cooler going to
stick it out and that it's not going to
be uh
pretty when you wear it so we want to
have a
distance right here is roughly about 0.5
to 1 millimeter
okay so then the next one is we need to
kind of uh thinking about how many do
you want it it basically models ring the
the more children that you have the mod
you you are going to make
right so i'm going to make five um so
i'm going to
coming over here and using my rotate
tool copy equal yes
and let's see the distance how much it
need to be from there i'm just going to
guess about
minus 20. and see if that doesn't work
okay and if it does okay for you just
minus
40 and then we don't need to do the
other side because we can just
mirror it right so ideally this distance
here you want to keep it about 0.1
millimeter
to 0.2 millimeter and so you do not want
them to
jamming each other because um
the stone will crack you do not want
them to be far far away
because the closer you get you get more
reflection
all right so this is a range for the
stone
and the next things i'm thinking about
it's going to do the underside
bezel so i'm going to coming over here
on my top view
and basically i want to make a tube
there so i'm going to
snapping into the vertex on the bottom
of the ring
and coming over here basically as long
as
they can be smaller than your stone you
don't
see the metal behind it that will be
fine
and roughly about this size all right
and i'm going to bring down like longer
than what i need at my front view you
can see
it's going like this once i have this
tube i usually like to have a balance is
slightly
taper so i'm going to use my gumball
and holding on the control shift and
pick up the bottom piece and kind of
scale it down a little bit so then it
will be tapered a little bit
okay if that look good to you you wanted
to
duplicate it to other side so we're
going to use the same
command for rotate snapping into the
zero
and rotating in the same degree minus
20 minus 40
and we get something like this i also
want to do the prong
by drawing a straight line snapping into
the grid from here roughly to here
and then i also need to rotate this guy
and
since it is in the middle it's going to
be share prong
so i'm going to rotate it again from the
center
and for only minus 10 degree
right there okay so now i don't need
this one
anymore that's uh coming over here
and let's pipe it so i'm going to
pipe it with the diameter you can
eyeball and see which one works for you
but you want to make sure it's thick
enough
that way that you can have a stone cut
on both sides so i'm going to have it
roughly about this size
and that will be my prong now having the
prong right in the middle is going to
cut
so much in there so i'm going to move it
up a little bit something like that
and that is equally cutting on the both
side all right
you do not want to have a problem it's
like coming out too much
like this because when you're buffing it
will be gone
there's too much pressure there so you
want to be
something in between just a little bit
lower
right in the middle um the strong is
higher than this prong
all right once you like it go ahead
go ahead to mirror this one
to the other side okay so now i have a
prong in place
i'm going to pick up both of them and
let me do the copy
with rotate with the copy option so
again
i want to rotate it minus 20 and
also minus 40.
all right so now i have this hello they
all look good
but to make it look more elegant i
actually want to have only
one prong at the end so to move it back
instead of moving
back and forth like this i would like to
use the
align with the center and just type in
zero then they were coming in
right on the construction plane
okay so if everything look good to you
i'm gonna pick up
everybody here
and simply just mirror to the other side
snapping into the zero
hit enter then i have things like that
one more thing i like to do
is having a window cut out right in the
middle here
and that allow more light to go through
so i'm gonna pick
uh with my gumball just going to scale
it up
somewhere here making a copy by tapping
the alt key
and do it again holding the shift
and tapping with the a
all right so now this is the two new
curve we have
simply let's go ahead to uh make them
into the solid by
straight extrusion and once we extrude
it
we can do is come in the front view i
would like to use the
[Music]
bowling difference this guy this guy
this guy and this and this one
will be cut by this all right so then we
have that opening over there
okay so now we have things like that and
i make it extra long it's because
i can trim it off very clean at once
so let's go ahead to pick up everybody
and bullying union
everyone so that become one piece and
then we can pick up this one
and let's go ahead to extrude this
straight
and we want to cut the bottom all at
once so bowling difference
this guy will be different out of this
guy
all right so now we finish the setting
bring back to the stone
and this is what we have here all right
so now we need to deal with the shank
for the shank i would like to uh using
the
conic corner on the rectangle snapping
into
on the side for the end point here and
want to do
the shank for 1.5 millimeter by
1.5 millimeter okay and
right there i'm going to simply just
using the move command to move
this point back to this point all right
so now it's right in the center
and let's go ahead to mirror to the
other side
and holding the shift so you will get
this to the other side
all right once you got that let's finish
the bottom of the ring shank first
so we're gonna use the surface tool you
got sweep one
and you got this cross section
and make sure they are aligned inside of
a ring shank
and you hit enter so that will be about
it
the top i actually like to have it a
little bit wider more like a spoon
kind of a shape over there so i'm gonna
coming over here
and simply going to draw some shape
uh they look something like this
about this y and we can we can keep
changing if we want to
and then i also wanted to have a
straight line
roughly from here down and we are going
to use the commands for
blend i got blend from here to here
and if you see something like that
pretty much it's because they are not
aligned so if we take a look on the side
you're going to see this curve is right
there
halfway in the middle and then this
curve is right there all right so to
make them work
nicely we're going to pick up both of
them
and we want to project it
to the construction plane and make sure
we want to delete the input
all right so now they are right in the
middle as you can see i marked them into
the red color
so now we come back here let me hide in
this one
what we're going to do is we're going to
use the blend command
and i'm going to blend from here to here
so it's nice and smooth and having this
one
to mirror to the other side
like this okay and double make sure if
this is the curve you like and you can
join it
now we have this curve and i basically
need an opening there
because i cannot have the curve
connected so i'm going to trim the
middle off
and take this circle off so basically
i do not want them to connect and then
they will have a better sweep there
i want to draw a line from here to here
and make sure it's roughly the same
position maybe this one needs to be just
a little bit lower there
so coming over here we got curved front
two view
and the first curve is this
the second curve is this again first
curve
second curve so now you can see i have
something like this
right now we are going to do is
using a sleep two rail you got rail one
rail two you got this cross section
and then you get this huge bump there
but it's okay
if we maintain the high it will come
back there
and let's just click okay right
so then we will have this shape there
i'm going to turn on what i have there
and basically on my front view i wanted
that piece
we just made and mirror to the other
side
over there and join to the bottom of the
ring shank
all right don't forget to cap it so it
will become
solid so now what we need to do is cut
it out something in the middle so what
you can do
is using this two curve and then you
want to offset
them uh inside uh for whatever thickness
you want i have it here for
uh 0.8 millimeter bringing in like this
and this one too i'm going to bring in
like this
if we look at this one i actually
need to close them so i basically
wanted to use the blank command to bring
back here and here
and then on the bottom one right here
and here they're going to trim each
other
okay having something really pointy may
be hard for do the fit
later on so i'm going to giving a little
fit it
so we want to fit it it for like point
four millimeter and see how it goes
maybe that's too big
maybe point two millimeter coming
here and here they look alright so i'm
going to join them
okay with that curve at this position
and if you like it to be higher you can
just move it higher
we're simply going to use this curve to
trim the surface there
all the way so then i have something
like this
okay and to close this surface
we we can use the commands called loft
and we're gonna loft from this guy to
this guy hit enter
click ok the same thing you're gonna do
on the other side
loft from this edges to this edges
and click ok and don't forget to join
them
all right if that look okay to you go
ahead to
uh making a small fillet
so let's say 0.15
and i'm gonna click it here
and that's working and we're gonna click
it here
and that's working too so let's do the
same thing on here and here
for 0.15 all right so that will be
our modest ring and happy mother's day
for all the mother in the world i wish
you have a very good holiday
and thank you for watching and i will
see you next
[Music]
you